Julia Roberts
Julia Roberts did something the other
day
that I I have to focus on because no one
is really talking about it and it's so
great it's one of the most positive
developments I've seen out of Hollywood
in a long time in large part I think
because it took place outside of
Hollywood
there was a piece in the New York Times
there was a long interview with Julia
Roberts and she stood up for
homemakers Julia Roberts is 54 years old
now
and she addressed her long absence from
rom-coms we haven't seen big Julia
Roberts rom-coms in many many years at
this point
she said here's the thing if I'd thought
that a script was good enough I would
have done it but I also had three kids
in the last 18 years that raises the bar
even more because then it's not only is
this material good it's also the math
question the math equation of my
husband's work schedule and the kids
school schedule and summer vacation it's
not just oh I think I want to do this I
have a sense of great pride in being
home with my family and considering
myself a homemaker you go girl I love
this this is so I don't just love this
because Julia Roberts is exalting
traditional standards and a traditional
way of life
I love it because she is expressing her
joy to lots of women who need to hear
this
because what she's saying is objectively
true and it is a better way of life and
it's much more conducive to happiness
than what lots of women are being fed in
school and by the popular culture which
is that they need to ditch having a
family put off getting married put off
having kids possibly indefinitely and
just go work in the widget Factory for
some other guy until they're too old to
have kids and then they can be really
regretful about that
Julia Roberts is sending a message here
and it's in the New York Times I can't
believe the New York Times let this
through
that is so
I I never want to hear again from some
feminist that look forget about having a
family forget about and look I'm not
saying everyone needs to get married and
have kids there's religious life there
are other callings as well but forget
about all that forget about all those
important significant things in life the
most important thing to do is to go work
in middle management and do spreadsheets
alone in my studio apartment in some big
city that's the most important thing I
could possibly do and nothing else
matters that's just a lie I never want
to hear it from them again because the
people who say that have really
relatively modest careers Julia Roberts
has one of the most spectacular
professional careers of any woman of her
age
and she kind of gave it up
she could have gone much for it she
could have done a whole lot more movies
she could have made tens of millions
more dollars at least and she didn't she
said no that money that Fame that
celebrity that adulation is actually not
worth anywhere near
the value of having a home having a
family having kids who love me going on
summer vacation with the kids having
making dinner
do going over homework with the kids
these are really
basic
things that we used to understand in our
traditional way of life that for all
times throughout all of history in all
places certainly in our civilization and
in many other civilizations as well we
have known or true and there is a
concerted effort by political radicals
to upend and to deny and to pervert all
of those things don't let them do it you
will be the victim if you let them do if
it won't be a great cause of Liberation
it won't be a way to finally overcome
the Bourgeois terrible oppression of the
past you will be the victim it will make
your life worse cling hold on to those
Traditional Values they are what are
going to Fetter us to reality into a
flourishing way of life right now go to
rockauto.com enter Knowles in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you the value of your car
or pickup truck or minivan or whatever
you drive has almost certainly
appreciated significantly this past year
will take care of your Automotive
investment keep more of your money by
buying the auto parts that you need to
maintain and repair your vehicle at
rockauto.com rockauto.com not only has
the auto parts that you need but they
will give you a selection of trusted
name brands to choose from you pick the
breaks that match how you use your
vehicle whether that's for towing racing
or just commuting to work which in my
case would be the same thing as racing
you can get exactly what you need super
duper easy to navigate website so simple
even I can do it same price for pros and
do-it-yourselfers these guys have been
with us since the very beginning of this
show we love them at rockauto.com head
on over there right now for your auto
parts and then write Knowles kwles in
there how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you
I'm glad you like that clip now ring the
bell subscribe get all the notifications
don't miss a single one unless YouTube
doesn't send them to you which you know
listen I've heard sometimes so if you
want to make sure you get all the
notifications go to the audio podcast
Spotify Stitcher Google play Apple
podcasts wherever you get your audio
podcast for free subscribe to the
Michael Knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-knowles leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you